[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
au menu les élections européennes
l'éventuelle référendum le complotisme
qui est très partagé par les français et
pour en parler à nos services bellina
bonjean patrie ça va bien ça va bien
cette enseignante à l'université de
rouen et à ses os politique exactement
et à côté 12 ans baptiste et du caire
bonjour patrice ont suivi pour un merci
pour le compte est bon pour satisfaire à
des universités de verser sa non pas
évidemment stéphane rousseau bon
évidemment un bon jab reprise c'est le
professeur montceau vérité de verser 50
vous essayez aussi mais oui mais oui
nous sommes entre gens très très
différent très divers une traîne
d'université mais elle est d'ailleurs
une théorie du complot
non il ya un complot des mucistes le
fameux complot des publicistes l acquis
il ya aussi le complot des éditeurs il
est terrible c'est terrible parce que
vous savez ce qu'il faut il y délivre
oui c'est cet ide des bouquets à
couverture noire et jaune en plus moi je
ne vous dis que ça je ne sais pas mais
comme disent assez ou pas mais qui
publient des appels rafale si vous êtes
succès des éditions l'a redit le complot
et c'est la première pierre du complot
beauvières pièces du complot
c'est un livre de marc valvo absolument
et c'est un polar
un vrai roman noir comme bien comme on
les aime voilà comme comme vous les
aimez je suis sûr c'est qu'on pense à
james hadley chase a faim c'est bon le
vrai roman noir classique si c'est au
cinéma on pourrait aussi bien voire lino
ventura qu que gérard lanvin dans le
rôle-titre enfin c'est vraiment un truc
aujourd'hui plus de gens voilà c'est
pour ça que si on n'imagine pas chez
nous
et puis sinon on verrait bien on verrait
bien un très très beau roman très beau
roman noir de marc valvo rafale voilà
éditions la joie dit absolument
alors il ya beaucoup de 6 évidemment
d'autres il ya quelqu'un qu'on connaît
bien ici qui s'appelle françois sévigny
puisqu'on l'a reçu à plusieurs reprises
qui est deux qui te normal y est un
professeur agrégé de philosophie qui a
fait un livre récent qui s'appelle
demeure dans lequel il lut un peu confus
henry ils s'opposent à cette réforme
l'idée de réformer sans cesse d'associer
des c'est donc françois davy bellamy et
on a appris c'était une rumeur qui s'est
confirmée c'est pas un complot qui
serait la tête de liste des républicains
aux élections européennes
d'abord est-ce qu'un intellectuel comme
tête de liste
vous trouvez ça plutôt encourageant
plutôt bien plutôt dans le nouveau
dégagé au milieu des mouvements des
gilets jaunes ça fait du bien on va
enfin voir quelqu'un qui parle aux qu'on
peut comprendre avec des mots des
phrases un sujet un verbe complément des
verbes conjugués des puits des idées qui
peuvent ne pas être les nôtres mais moi
il ya des idées
donc c'est maintenant ça va être plutôt
agréable c'est une bonne nouvelle
ces droits vive les intellos au pouvoir
s'était pas donné son nom mais c'est
plus et un esprit assez à ses fins enfin
qu'on soit d'accord ou pas vraiment mais
je voyais en écoutant votre question je
pensais au aux universitaires alors j'ai
pas si on peut on peut les qualifier
d'intellectuels ou pas pas forcément
parce que l'intellectuel sont quand même
une une figurine quand ça dure
engagé dans l'annoncé dans la nuit la
vie politique sociale figure de
l'intellectuel
et je hais je réalisais à quel point en
règle générale l'engagement des
universités en politique était une
catastrophe
enfin conduisait en général à des chefs
d'antenne 2 2 co la gamme ou jeudi a
fait nos deux collègues qui qui qui est
qui était au temps où il était à
l'université d'excellents arrêts
éminents collègues mais les tentatives
de pénétration de la sphère politique
par les universités en général ce marché
oui mais je je je l'étais rêve si vous
me permettez pas parce qu'il y est
robert badinter robert badinter avocat
l'université oui il est il était
professeur dans privé mais il était
évidemment plus connus et reconnus comme
black jack et et willy a été aussi de
réussite mais des exemples de ces
tentatives quand même j'en ai beaucoup
mais de nombreux ballons et et pour
quelle raison à votre avis à la fin
c'est intéressant pourquoi ça ne colle
pas quoi que ça colle pas parce que ça
vaille est la différence entre la
théorie et la pratique
mais ça c'est un reproche qu'on fait on
fait trop aux universités oui c'est plus
à l'université mais y'a oui entre entre
les enjeux de la manière dont on peut
s'exprimer dans un amphithéâtre où dans
un colloque est celle dont on peut
s'adresser aux électeurs et des trucs
parfois une différence qui n'est pas qui
n'est pas fait mais en tout cas moi je
me oui oui je me réjouis de l'arrivée
en effet comme comme jean-charles tout
le monde rit de l'intellectuel en
politique c'est quand même un fleuron
français on en a on a ça dans notre
culture en règle générale depuis la 2ème
république a été une république alors
justement là on l'a on a un peu
considéré comme trop théorique parce
qu'elle avait été faite par des
intellectuels mais
avec victor hugo lamartine beaucoup
voilà alors elle n'a pas duré très
longtemps
néanmoins c'est vrai que même à quoi les
dogues n'ont ici mais c'est vrai que
l'intellectuel en politique c'est quand
même aussi une figure c'est aussi
quelque chose qui permet de redorer
entièrement pensé à malraux avec bon
voilà il ya il ya toujours eu quelques
heures voilà il ya eu quelques illustres
la figure de l'intellectuel c'était
pardon je voulais cela parle de ces
après vais vous parler de la figure de
l'intellectuel n'est pas forcément vrai
clavier cure de l'intellectuel en france
elle s'est plutôt positionné contre
c'est à dire c'est plutôt ça retrouver
la l1 vaut mieux avoir raison avec saft
que temps avec sartre que raison avec
avec aarau c'est la fameuse phrase mais
c'est vrai que la figure de
l'intellectuel c'était plutôt qu'outre
le vôtre leval d'état politique contre
parfois la démocratie libérale à dire ce
qu'on veut l'intellectuel en politique
c'est à dire dans une fonction politique
ou en dehors d'une fonction politique en
ont dû système appelé cette fonction
peut or moi je trouve que cette place
est bien meilleure parce que justement
l'intellectuel c'est clair c'est la
liberté de pensée c'est la hauteur et
donc évidemment lorsqu'on rentre dans
une fonction politique dans un parti
politique on est contraint par des
logiques de systèmes par des obligations
j'imagine que même bellamy a dû prendre
des engagements vis-à-vis de vos pieds
de me taire certaines certaine opinion
notamment conservatrice et donc compte
tenu notamment des enjeux européens
parce que tu avais la fonction et
l'institution justement enlève ce qui
fait de la superbe de l'intellectuel
donc moi je le préfère en dehors
l'intellectuel en dois je vous propose
de regarder deux réactions à la
désignation de françois lamy comme tête
de liste c'est celle de valérie pécresse
et celle du président du sénat gérard
larcher
c'est une personne que de grande valeur
et pour lequel j'ai beaucoup d'estimé et
d'amitié
mais ses positions sur un certain nombre
de sujets de société ne sont pas les
miennes et je ne veux pas qu'on pense
que les positions sur les sujets de
société de françois-xavier bellamy sont
celles de la droite française
je ne veux pas qu'on que les sujets de
sociétés viennent polluer notre campagne
européenne
en tous les cas nous attendons la suite
de la lys donc clairement je soutiendrai
et accompagnerez cette liste mais il est
vrai que
ce choix là n'était pas mon choix mais
je suis dans une famille politique je
suis aux côtés de la famille politique
s'il peut dire il ya à boire et à manger
encore ses réactions
on voit tout de suite comme ça il ya
quand même l'honneur
alors c'est vrai que il a d e et d
engagement personnel prêt à ses proches
de 2,2 d'humour qui s'appelle sens
commun qui étaient contre le mariage
pour tous aussi contre l'avortement et
c'est vrai que ça dit quoi au fond que
de choisir quelqu'un qui a en effet une
image assez conservatrice moi je pense
qu'on vient parler d'un intellectuel on
peut pas non plus résumé quelqu'un à
deux positions qui sont effectivement
pas du tout dans la norme et dans le
dans le dogme actuel en déclassant ces
deux positions il est bien clair que
l'avortement tous on ya pas d by
personne ne propose de l'euro mais qu'il
a derrière lui comme ça c'est après
qu'on soit ce revenir c'est pareil mais
on peut enfin il a quand même le droit
d'avoir des opinions qui ne sont pas les
nôtres c'est pas c'est pas dramatique
tête de liste oui bien sûr non mais
qu'est le droit dans la vie c'est que ce
n'est pas le principal le programme
politique qui défend
voilà donc ses opinions personnelles le
dire il n'est pas jusqu'à présent il n'a
jamais été question pour les
républicains de remettre en cause ni
l'avortement ni le mariage pour tous
donc ses vassaux il sait ce qu'ils
pensent et bien voilà peu tant pis c'est
pas le programme donc là c'est qui ment
on peut voter ou ne pas voter pour une
personne mais c'est avant d'être une
personne c'est la tête du de liste d'un
parti et d'un programme donc ces deux
points n'étant pas dans le programme
pour moi c'est un peuple que
l'importance prêt à titre personnel with
love est ce qu est ce que est ce que
derrière ça il y a on a beaucoup des glo
wauquiez droitisée
le bourg et publica est ce que c'est une
marque de cette droitisation c'est ça la
question
c'est un léger marqueur mais en même
temps c'est pas complètement idiot non
plus de la part de leur ressenti
on voit bien qu'il ya pas d espace au
centre et il va pas aller non parce
qu'en bas de son histoire les numéros 2
et et le juppéiste no3 et pâques recist
ces passionnés nous créons grossistes ça
sonne bien creux mois ce qui n'est pas
sûr qu'elle aime mais au moins cette
galère - décret soit si je viens garde
regardons progressiste à mon sens c'est
pas le candidat plus consensuel c'est
vraiment ce qu'on peut dire c'est pour
ça que c'est étonnant parce que c'est
vrai que l'on pouvait s'attendre à ce
que ça soit bon voilà déjà aussi une
personnalité peut-être un petit peu plus
connu des français parce que bon il a
créé un petit peu la surprise même temps
les députés européens sortants de des
républicains hortefeux dati et c'est à
ce domaine parmi les plus mauvais
députés européens qui ont déjà vu une
bonne chose
il était temps qu'on renouvelle un petit
peu notre notre offre produits seront
sur les listes et ils veulent tous être
position éligible à mon avis c'est
peut-être le choix aussi d'une idéologie
c'est à dire d'essayer de recréer une
droite des idées un petit peu c'est
beaucoup ce qu'on lui a en tout cas
affiché comme étiquette bien avant
d'ailleurs qu'il soit désignée comme
telle est l'idée européenne c'était la
droite a enfin retrouvé son souffle sa
pensée à l'origan soeur voilà ce côté
intellectuel a peut-être amené laurent
wauquiez à choisir un ce sera un choix
qui pour le coup est loin d'être une
intelligente à mon avis qui est celui de
la stratégie de positionnement en se
disant voilà on recrée une droite des
idées en essayant peut-être aussi de
créer le débat
être dans l'opposition être dans le
dérangeant un petit peu c'est aussi une
manière de se faire entendre
on oublie d y recevoir que vos qui est
aussi un normalien il était major de
l'agrégation d'histoire était major de
l'ena et qu'il a inscrit aussi
intellectuel si je veux dire baby loup
un peu d'imagination qui la subissent et
peut-être de manière extrêmement
maladroite
il faut peut-être qu'à un moment on
revient à ses premières amours
ce qui est marquant au delà du fait
savoir évidemment une droitisation alors
je pense pas que la stratégie sera
payante parce que je crois beaucoup au
fait que les électeurs préfèrent
toujours l'original à la copie
et qu'à courir derrière le rassemblement
national wauquiez le finir et souffler
mais ce mois ce qui marque dans ces
affaires c'est que jamais on ne parle
d'europe
alors on dit la bbc temps il ya le temps
s'étant mais mais mais c'est terrible
c'était épouvantable
c'est épouvantable au regard de l'aspect
capital important impérieux de l'enjeu
européen
on n'en parle pas jamais on parle comme
d'habitude par la politique par le biais
de recomposition et sert alors par le
biais de la crise franco-italienne ville
at il maugréé dernier rapport de leur
âme à laisser l'ambassadeur je trouve ça
assez assez terrible qu'une fois de plus
à l'occasion ce scrutin européen et
c'est plutôt mal parti on passe à côté
de l'essentiel
comme d'habitude comme d'habitude comme
souvent en fin d'année y en a qu'un à
mon avis qui a fait une bonne campagne
européenne dans l'histoire c'était cohn
bendit y avait un qui avait parlé
d'europe et qui avait fait un excellent
score
enfin le meilleur score je pense des
écolos des élections européennes on va
contacter leurs proches que c'est enfin
je rends laurent wauquiez responsables
de cela c'est à dire qu'en désignant
bellamy comme tête de liste
il ne pouvait pas ne pas savoir qu'on
allait l'enfermer dans les enjeux de
société et qu'on allait complètement
éclipsé le débat sur sur l'europe et sur
l'union européenne
donc pour moi c'est un choix volontaire
de
de cette tête de liste fin de vos qu'est
pardon de faire qu'on ne parle pas
d'europe et qu'on parle de ses idées
conservatrices puisque bon et moi c'est
donc après ce que tu dis un char c'est
où on parle pas d'europe mais c'est
précisément le but d l'air finalement à
travers c'est un suivi sur toi c'est
aussi en fin de ligne à l'horizon une
double
les républicains sont un peu ils sont
pas par tradition plutôt pro européen et
pour ne pas sauter un électorat plus
souverainiste
il préfère proposer de choix d'affichage
c'est à dire que d'être dans la
contestation d'être dans la critique
ça permet de se faire entendre et le
vrai problème des républicains en ce
moment c'est de passer aussi pour une
entité un peu inexistante un peu molle
entre le rassemblement national et le
centre et au moins ça leur donne déjà on
en parle
donc c'est peut-être aussi le premier
objet m'équipe en effet aubert
complètement là
la finalité qui est celle des
européennes mais au moins on pas aussi
de le le projet européen ne sont ne sont
pas non plus être la principale
préoccupation des français ni la
principale préoccupation des gilets
jaunes enfin à voir ce qui se dit sur
les ronds points donc c'est pas
complètement idiot non plus de mettre
l'accent sur un type comme bellamy et et
tout ce qui peut déclencher comme
réaction donc c'est une stratégie alors
cette phrase vivait cette phrase
commandes de marion maréchal qui était
un peu un peu antérieure à la
désignation de françois xavier bellamy
qui disait si une personnalité comme
françois xavier b d'amis se confirme je
ne vois pas ce qui empêcherait qu'il
puisse y avoir des alliances dans des
circonstances électorales
c'est bon c'est pas très foncée mais
c'est vrai que c'est assez intéressant
parce que est ce que le rassemblement
national aussi conservateur sur des
problèmes sociétaux qu'une fraction de
la droite dure de rein que représente
paris on ne réfléchit pas si sûr que ça
on les avait pas beaucoup vu dans l'est
dans les manifestations pour tous
labellisation à leur assemblée nationale
dans sa normalisation a quand même comme
est pas mal et ce qu'il a fait des
orphelins et fait feu de toute la
la joie est là aussi cette extrême
droite qui représente ses textes à la
française entre l'historique qui
représente un très joli 5 pour cent le
litre à est plutôt du côté de de la
nièce bref l'eau qui attend son heure au
demeurant ça j'en suis j'en suis assez
de l'invaincu après faut pas non plus
être trop caricatural on peut aussi
avoir les positions certes un peu
curieuse de bellamy et voir des
dépositions sur des problèmes de société
qui ne sont pas ceux de la majorité des
gens dans les média experts n'en ont pas
sans être d'extrême droite
on peut être contre les matins mais on
peut être contre le mariage pour tous et
ne pas être d'extrême droite on peut
être
voilà donc le gamin puisqu'on a toujours
tendre et les rebelles pensent comme ça
donc ils vont se rapprocher du front
national banon il ya plein de gens en
france qui sont pas d'extrême droite et
qui n'était pas pour le moins michel
renard je me souviens qu'ils terminent
indiqué par le fait qu on appelle ça
mariage voilà donc ces hybrides
précisément à l'extrême droite
au moins on reparle de la droite qu'est
ce que la droite et c'est vrai
qu'historiquement si on prend les
ouvrages rené rémond les droites en
france etc
on a toujours eu une droite
conservatrice une droite plus libéral et
dans cette droite conservatrice ya
évidemment une influence de la religion
de sur les questions sociétales et on
retourne un peu aux fondamentaux avec
cela sans être d'extrême droite
attention on voit quand même les
républicains ils sont 12% 12% c'était à
peu près un peu plus mais à peine que ce
qu'avait fait sarkozy soit c'était quand
il venait la liste rpr
c'est ce qui avait été quand une tour de
catastrophe
c'est pas énorme c'est très peu c'est
très vraiment c'est le concept du nom ça
c'est extrêmement faible mais mais il ya
alors on est un peu le fil et allemand
de la palette il le spectre est
tellement large chacun chacun veut y
aller un doigt gauche et puis les
sondages faux souvenez-vous de chirac
six mois avant d'être élu président de
la république il est à moins de 10% des
deux pignons en forme et donc et puis là
et puis là c'est vrai que comme le dit
stéphane de personne ne parle de
l'europe
alors si des deux qui en parle et c'est
qui c'est qui ce que j'ai en tête c'est
serré public en mars et s'est rallié au
national
je sais pas qui l'on parle abondamment
mais enfin on connaît les positions
c'est vrai qu'il ya vraiment eu un
clivage est au tour de la wii c'est
plutôt je trouve ça très bien qu'ils
aient un clivage autour d'une question
aussi fondamentale que celle de l'europe
qui rejoint d'ailleurs d'autres clivages
enfin qui ce dans la même dans la même
mouvance dans la même lignée mais vous
avez raison
même si alors le clivage a évolué
puisque on sait que le rassemblement
national à réviser comme un oui c'est
plus pour la position est intenable ne
serait ce que que quand on regarde a
expliqué explicables et n'exclut pas la
bienvenue aux débats non seulement
c'était compliqué à expliquer a quand
même au sort s'en sortiront sans sortir
sortant c'est compliqué mais sauf qu'on
a vu à quel point elle était sur ces
aspects-là extrêmement médiocre et
qu'elle n'était évidemment pas destinée
à occuper les plus hautes fonctions
alors un petit point sur l'agent
françois xavier musca 33 ans on aura
jordan bardet la tête de liste rassemble
nationale qui à 23 ans mano briguer la
tête de liste france a soumises 30 ans
c'est pas bien si le père de yannick
jadot voyage à dos et un peu vieux de la
vieille quand même c'est du grand art
mais c'est fait ça fait quand même nous
rajeunissement bon pour moi c'est plus
renouvellement cra jaunissement c'est
parce que enfin il ya des jeunes qui
sont très vieux très vite et des vieux
qui reste très jeune pour moi c'est pas
beau nom mais c'est plus que le
philosophe je dis cela mais pour moi
c'est une fausse question c'est pas un
problème mais ce qu'il faut c'est que si
ce qui est du renouvellement la jeunesse
c'est en dise rien à faire comme
chantait brassens la gêne et c'est très
bien c'est un problème qui seront mis
fin il ya quand même
une fois qu'il est de l'île s'appelle
jordan surtout le nom wii des besoins
pourquoi pas 18 aussi nommé c on s'est
peut-être pas mal auprès tous doivent à
un moment on dit que par exemple dans le
grand des grands débats ont refait les
ânes sont plutôt absents le fait qu'ils
aient d'aider des plus jeunes qui
prennent la place dans cette peau c'est
peut-être une bonne sono passage alors
je sais pas si je rétrograde un peu mais
j'ai le sentiment que le dater dans
marche en fait j'ai le sentiment qu'on a
rajeuni renouveler beaucoup à partir des
législatives de 2010 elles mêmes
auparavant avec les marcheurs au moment
de l'élection présidentielle c'était le
postulat des manuels macro moins de dire
voilà tous dehors on en a marre on a
envie de renouveler les têtes et lui
même avec sa jeunesse numérique et bien
il est venu amener avec lui toute une
troupe de nouveau et de plus jeunes on y
fait donc est ce que c'est la jeunesse
delajoux voilà on dit que la valeur
n'attend pas le nombre des années
donc voilà je ne sais pas ce que ça va
donner néanmoins c'est vrai que ça
correspond à un besoin de renouvellement
qui était quand même nécessaire depuis
un petit moment et puis on n'est pas les
seuls dans l'europe à avoir renouvelé et
rajeuni nos listes jusqu'à présent fin
les têtes de listes européennes passées
si bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on prend
l'histoire ou giscard c'est des gens qui
avaient un passé - poids politique très
fort c'est intéressant quand même que
l'on prenne d'aider des gens qui n'ont
jamais été hué quoi ce qui serait
surtout intéressant c'est qu'il soit bon
en plus d'être jeune quand même s'il est
allé à celle ci
on se demande par moment s'ils n'ont pas
été choisis certains uniquement parce
qu'il était jeune le marron à ce niveau
il a 41 ans c'est quelqu'un qui est bon
qui est brillant mais qui est jeune on
top
moi ce que je trouve inquiétant c'est la
jeunesse politique pas la jeunesse de
l'état civil alors souvent quand on est
très jeune effectivement on n'a pas
d'expérience politique
mais moi le plus inquiétant c'est ça
c'est à dire qu'au début moi j'étais
assez pour cette idée du renouvellement
de changer et puis on a un peu de
retours d'expérience par rapport à ce
qui s'est passé avec la reine et
finalement je trouve que regard de ce
qui se passe à l'assemblée au regard de
ce qui se passe même à la présence de la
république finalement je suis assez déçu
et je trouve que alors trop d'expérience
et peut-être aussi veut pas forcément
une bonne chose mais un peu d'expérience
me paraît finalement assez utile même
bellamy qui n'a pas d'expérience
politique qui arrive en politique et qui
dit mais je ne comprends pas on ne peut
pas débattre il n'y a pas d'espacé pour
le débat je pensais que le niveau
intellectuel est très élevé et en fait
ils découvrent l'arène politique quoi
donc ici de traiter national populisme
par jadot c'est ça la politique donc il
faut aussi reconnaître un petit peu les
tenants et les aboutissants et puis
savoir aussi manoeuvré par se faire la
politique c'est connaître les
institutions et et ça c'est aussi un
travail
quoiqu'il qu'il faut maîtriser et cela
me va effectivement d une atmosphère un
peu moins feutrée au conseil municipal
de versailles
quelques têtes rasées animé foot attend
il est aujourd'hui un peu entre gens du
même monde
il faut signaler qu'il était il avait
été candidat aux législatives dans les
yvelines
et alors il a été un des victimes de la
vague en marche mais il était dans une
circonscription a priori imperdable week
a été découpée de manière à ce qu'elle
soit imperdable pour la droite gauche
droite et fn il était quand même été
battus believe et il y avait la vague la
vague en marche assez bon voilà qui
était laquelle il était difficile de
résister on a posé à rappeler lorsqu'il
était sur le plateau
et si vous étiez des conseillers
politiques par exemple puisqu'on ne
connaît toujours pas la tête de liste
dans le match on mettrait plutôt vieux
on pense aux familles des affaires
étrangères par exemple un vieux avec de
l'est beaucoup d'expérience parce que je
trouve que c'est par ce rapport j'allume
ray un contre-feu je ferai une contre
programmation
parce que je trouve que cette jeunesse
magnifique parfait l'avenir de notre
pays l'avenir de mes retraite
en tout cas c'est pas si on a réfléchi
deux minutes c'est pas un bon signal me
semble-t-il au regard encore une fois de
la manière dont on conçoit à la question
européenne en france c'est à dire que
j'ai l'impression je caricature sans
doute mais qu'on se dit on essaie ça aux
enfants
envoyer des jeunes est bon de faire les
dents parce que il n'y a aucun enjeu on
s'en fout ce sont les élections
européennes personne n'en a rien à faire
et justement le fait de voir vous
évoquiez giscard simone veil est il des
têtes de liste assez emblématique à
l'échelon européen qui avait fait quand
même beaucoup pour la construction
européenne c'est m me semble-t-il aussi
un signal de de prise de conscience de
l'importance des enjeux
à cette réserve près qu'ils aient eu
aussi beaucoup de têtes de listes qui
n'ont jamais cv 1
ray grass vous il y avait été tête de
liste je ne sais plus quand qu'avait
pris l'engagement brest et siéger à
strasbourg et qui au bout de deux mois à
démissionner oui mais j'ai d'autres
je pense à hollande emporterait c'était
même un peu pathétique qu'en face de la
terre des gens qui se faisaient dire
qu'il démissionnait touchées d'après
pour s'occuper de politique intérieure
mais ça c'est peut-être à la limite plus
honnête que ceux qui sont restés sans
sont sûrs d'y aller il s'engage et nous
avons des nous et on a dénombré sucre
pour faire la politique nationale un
coup vicieux dit tout le mal qu'il pense
de l'europe mais qui meglio show m
attendais pas mal profite en un mot
terminer là dessus peut-être que aussi
le contre-feu c'est de trouver un
spécialiste de l'europe parce que vous
preniez de vérifier leur destin et
simone veil
c'est vrai qu'on manque cruellement de
personnes mais qui ont contribué à la
construction mais les libéraux qu'ils
étaient peut-être de l'histoire
à une époque c'était au fond c'était un
peu les chefs de partis qui étaient qui
était oui mais à la fin on prenait celui
pour y aller qui avait le plus de
compétences en la matière c'est
actuellement assez judicieux c'est
peut-être quelque chose qu'on oublie
trop donc un vieux pour la république ce
n'est pas rien non mais c'est vrai après
tout l'image de la jeunesse il loue avec
emmanuel macron donc ils l'ont déjà fait
cette jeunesse bref parfait mais on sait
que le titre du rassemblement national
on sait très bien que c'est la voix de
son maître et que huit été choisi pour
ça c'est pas lui qui parle bon ça c'est
pas lui faire injure
il y avait le grand débat qui s'est
poursuivie un peu partout en france avec
notamment la présidente la présence du
président de la république dans certains
lieux du 1er mai dans d'autres et puis
j'ai vu un débat cette trappe
regardez des petits extraits et puis on
va peut-être parler un peu de ce que si
ce débat par rapport aux partis
politiques
c'est l'une des réponses du gouvernement
à la crise des gilet jaune engagé le
grand débat national
la mise en place d'une grande
concertation de terrain a commencé à
trappes derrière cette initiative la
députée nadia est ce que j'attends fait
de ceux de cette journée c'est que la
parole soit vraiment l'île la plus libre
possible que personne ne saute aux
sanctions
un débat sous forme de petites tables
rondes par thématiques avec à chaque
pôle un rapporteur général pouvoir
d'achat fiscalité les discussions
étaient bien nourris
si l'état mettez le doigt sur cette
fiscalité l'exil fiscal qui nous coûte
80 milliards par an il travaille alors
que la france irait beaucoup mieux les
représentants des associations de
trappes ont également soumis leurs idées
on voudrait que l'état reprenne la
gestion des bailleurs c'est à dire en
profondeur c'est à dire de ce qu'ils
font de l'argent
les participants ne venait pas à tous de
trappes à l'image de cet habitant
militant pour une meilleure fiscalité et
avant de faire une réforme fiscale
commencé par produire des richesses que
l'exemple que j'ai pris avant de
distribuer les pommes elle va produire
les pommes certains citoyens en ont
profité pour interpeller la ministre de
la santé agnès buzyn souvent on a un
traitement par exemple pour quatre ou
cinq jours donne une boîte qui va durer
le traitement 160 jours
les traitements coup on est en train de
travailler sur la dispensation médicaux
enfin tout d'une part pilule les élus
locaux étaient également présents pour
ce grand débat il ya des décisions de
fond à prendre dans la solidarité
l'égalité
un certain nombre d'éléments
administratifs qu'ils sont superflus on
peut moderniser la france
elle en est capable et elle en a besoin
deux heures des échanges qui ont permis
aux élus députés et à la ministre de se
rendre compte de la situation sur le
terrain contre tout ce qui est fait au
niveau d'un gouvernement et la façon
dont ça se concrétise dans le quotidien
des gens et bien il ya une énorme et cas
c'est peut-être la leçon qu'on peut
tirer c'est que on doit se parler plus
fréquemment en direct tous les citoyens
attendent à présent la fin de ce grand
débat national pour voir sa finalité et
les décisions politiques qui seront
prises voilà c'est donc bon des extraits
d'un des multiples grad cette marche pas
si mal que ça d'ailleurs
non ben ça a l'air de bien fonctionner
surtout moi sauf un jeu l'enseignement
j'en tire c'est macron absolument
brillantissime
à chaque fois il est là mais extrêmement
séduisant et séducteur et brillant il
répond à toutes les questions
cette fois c'est dit réserve est ce que
c'est un gros des pas pour que il
répondait il explique ce qui fait d
peut-être pas sali des dons plus non ce
n'est pas une interview du saas et
ajouté d'ailleurs par la suite s'il
n'était pas du tout prévu au programme
donc lui c'est un peu l'inconnue du
matin celui qui parle c'est bien
tellement l'attention
alors je sais pas d'ailleurs si le
conçoivent comme quelque chose qui fait
partie du grand débat aussi lui a voulu
l'organiser un petit peu en parallèle de
ce grand débat pour notamment connecter
avec les élus il reste que du coup on a
le sentiment que les français ont font
un peu un packaging au bout il ya la
présence de emmanuel macron auprès des
maires de france
et puis la plateforme grand débat est ce
que l'un est complémentaire avec l'autre
on on pense aussi je pense aussi à
emmanuel macron entend personne en tant
président qui avait peut-être besoin
aussi de reprendre confiance en lui
d'abord et puis peut-être de reconnecter
un petit peu avec sa base donc il
retrouve aussi un petit peu là voilà les
l'émotion de la campagne les sondages en
plus et puis ça marche oui mais alors
justement l'apparition de ce mouvement
des villes et jaune
il est un petit peu l'apparition du nom
en mars il ya quelques années
évidemment c'est ce biais à une crise
des partis politiques traditionnels
mais la question qui se pose au fossé
est ce que ces nouveaux mouvements
prennent en compte les diversités que
incarner les partis politiques c'est à
dire les grands mouvements de la société
française libérale ou non
révolutionnaire le mouvement
antirévolutionnaire lhomond cathodique
etc qui ont créé les partis politiques
est-ce que
est ce que ces nouveaux sons cette même
capacité ou pas c'est un des problèmes
des jo de ces pour moi c'est enfin c'est
un nom mouvement ouah c'est un mouvement
sens physique mais pas au sens politique
pour l'instant démontre son incapacité à
transformer en en questionnement et
réponse politique des questions d'ordre
social culturel voire philosophique fin
plus profonde c'est ça le travail d'un
parti politique et c'est pas un gros mot
aux partis politiques vous entendez
maintenant tous là aujourd'hui c'est
qu'ils disent famille politique surtout
pas dire parti dont il ya eu d'abord
mouvement maintenant la version là la
france peut avoir à l'égard de crs et de
ses divisions de deux de ses ennemis de
l'intérieur comme on disait partis
politiques c'était un truc dont il
fallait se méfier et c'est alors que
c'est un instrument de démocratie mais
le la fonction d'un parti c'est aussi de
de transformer en message politique en
délibération politique des mouvements un
peu un peu réflexes un peu
il réfléchit comme ils canalisent edwy
de paix de transformer alors les jaunes
pour l'instant sont complètement
incapable parce qu'il ya tout n'importe
quoi et son contraire là dedans
côté la république en marche c'est alors
là c'est c'est en effet un parti
politique mais qu'à un côté assez
artificiel on n'est plus dans les partis
politiques que des traditionnels y
représenter des grands courants de dos
l'opinion
là où on était une machine à gadjo dilo
n'est plus dans le marketing au fond que
dans la creuse la politique parce que la
république en marche un parti à
l'américaine et certains très amaigris
dans une machine politique électorale
mais j'ai les lire mais qui se dégonfle
au moment là la victoire et pardon et la
preuve un peu cons et qu'on est dans ce
goût là c'était que des partis qui n'ont
plus cette capacité à être d'aider des
mouvements électoral pour ce parti
socialiste et ses foudres
mais moi la question que ça m'amène à me
poser c'est est ce que ces grands
mouvements que les partis représentés
dont vous parliez qui sont justement
donc la gauche plutôt social à gauche la
droite conservatrice et c est ce que ces
grands mots
sont encore des éléments qui permettent
aux français de se sentir représentés à
ce sont encore besoin moi je n'en suis
pas vraiment sûr d'autant que la mode
est donc en partie comme tu disais avec
en marche au parti présidentialiste quoi
c'est à dire qu' il est très différent
salle à manger beaucoup mangé avec voilà
cette théorisation qu'on voulait faire
des parties de cas des partis de masse
etc tout cela ça n'existe plus au profit
de partis à l'américaine c'est-à-dire
deux parties personnalisées on veut moi
je crois que le laisser des gilet jaune
alors pour maman n'arrive pas du tout à
être on transforme pas l'essai mais
c'est symptomatique du fait qu'on a
peut-être plus besoin des mouvements
traditionnels pour créer des choses qui
viennent plus de la base on peut penser
à podemos en espagne où précisément ces
mouvements des indignés qui a lui réussi
à se structurer ensuite pour proposer
une offre à lormont qui a donné ce
qu'elle a donné au moins c'est pas
forcément un exemple podemos et rydia on
peut en citer en voilà les king ouest l
on est en plein dans la vague des
mouvements qui n'ont plus d'identité
historique et qui ne sont pas justement
des mouvements voilà libéraux-démocrates
etc mais qui au moins partent de la base
est ce que c'est ce dont on a besoin est
ce que finalement il ne peut plus
exister que des partis de masse que les
caniveaux mort ne sont pas plus mal
parce que les clivages idéologiques
tombe en 1871
rendez vous compte on se battait pour on
est déjà pour une forme de gouvernement
partisan de l'anc est ce que c'était la
mode qu'est ce que c'est
et avec des enjeux c'était quelque chose
bon après on est tous républicains 3ème
4ème république bon il ya la parenthèse
vichy vème république alors après on est
allé pour ou contre l'économie de marché
encore jusqu'en 81-83 on est pour
l'économie de marché du parti communiste
jusqu'au mythique qui s'effrite ans je
parle tout cas de la vraie démocratie à
partir de 10 ans de la majorité bon et
83 on est pour l'économie marché plus ou
moins libéral et puis bah aujourd'hui la
gauche a disparu on est il ya une espèce
de magma
il ya des extrêmes et qui elle-même
rassemble aussi des gens qui ont des
idées qui sont pas forcément homogène on
parlait du rassemblement national
donc je crois qu'il ya une
homogénéisation des idées il ya une
perte d' idéologie a plus vraiment donc
c'est peut même nous interroger sur la
base de l'intellectuel puisque du coup
l'intellectuel c'est l'idée ait cessé
d'aimer mais quelle idée bon au pluriel
surtout vous voilà moment surtout ce que
je pense que ça fait lien avec la
théorie du complot c'est que finalement
le grand clivage qui existe maintenant
c'est le système est l'anti système est
précisément c'est ce qui crée aussi
cette émulation pour les extrêmes c'est
que il n'ya plus de positionnement de
différents courants de pensée mais il ya
être pour ou contre
en fait voilà on est devenus c'était
même le jean marie le pen avait un peu
théorique et ainsi comptées
l'établissement voit là mais sachant que
l'anti système est lui-même un système
regard sur non mais regardez dans quel
travers tombe les les gilets jaunes qui
souhaitent s'engager en politique et
monter des listes etc
je trouve c'est ça qu'il faut faire
voilà c'est réduire tout cela en langage
connaissent les obligations et donc
qu'il ya des scissions il ya des menaces
ya des machins ce sont les pires travers
ah oui de ce que la vie politique prêt e
donné mais d'un plan ce système est
lui-même un système presque nouveaux
écologistes
tous ces partis qu'on a cité pour des
mots syriza sont des partis qui se sont
cités au départ comme étant des partis
anti par contre c'est parti on unis
et c'est pareil pour les jets les jaunes
c'est pareil pour les gilles et jo on
est dans la mode des partis anti parti
pour la région et pour la raim également
partie de ce parti est un parti à léon
franc parler de constitution des listes
il ya sondages tout récent qui montre
que 55% des français seraient favorables
à l'organisation d'un référendum
le jour même des élections européennes
on dit que c'est une solution à laquelle
pense le président de la république et
en boucle quand même en refaire un peu
une histoire d'aider référendum ne
serait ce que sous la vème république
sans remonter jusqu'à napoléon iii mais
qui et qui mots pourquoi il ya pourquoi
il ya une défiance vis-à-vis du
référendum une défiance notamment
d'aider des dirigeants je risque 17
minutes
[Rires]
elle joue plutôt en fait des
responsables politiques et qui met alors
à ceci près que à l'origine lorsque la
vème république a été créé on a conçu
donc enfin le général de gaulle a
souhaité un exécutif extrêmement fort
extrêmement puissant avec de lourdes
responsabilités et il le général de
gaulle disait qu'à de grandes
responsables en cas de grand pouvoir
implique de grandes responsabilités et
cette responsabilité devait notamment
joué à travers le référendum référendum
pour lequel systématiquement lorsqu'il
en organiser un il en organise et tu as
laissé 4 et sur des grandes questions et
bien il engageait sa responsabilité
c'est à dire qu'ils disent mais voilà
encadré pineau sixième filet de venir
participer et en 69 il est même allé au
bout de sa logique et il est parti et
oui mais alors venez mais à l'époque
tout rappeler les débats entre
constitutionnalistes est-ce que c'est
des référendums est-ce que c'était
plébiscite enfin il y avait il y avait
même politique va des débats politiques
très très fort avec le sénat et c'est
avec merville
il y avait des opinions extrêmement
forte à l'époque c'est un sens
particulier de la responsabilité
politique puisque normalement le
référendum n'est pas censé être associé
à la
la responsabilité des élus c'est à dire
que a priori un et lui pose une question
au peuple lui donne le peuple donne une
réponse à laquelle le président doit
donner suite ou pas ce corollaire de la
responsabilité politique à mon sens ça
n'est pas nécessairement du ressort du
plébiscite pour le général de gaulle
puisque c'est quelque chose qu'il a
réellement pris à coeur néanmoins c'est
ça qui distingue le référendum du
plébiscite c'est de faire de cette
question un âge qu'il faudrait pouvoir
personnel voilà c'est ce qu'on avait
retenu aujourd'hui c'est vrai que quand
y ait un référendum on répond plus à la
personne cris poser les questions qu'à
la question elle-même un cessez le feu
et d'ailleurs les successeurs de du
général de gaulle ont su faire du
référentiel notamment eu peur de rien
mais nous a bénis leur mandat en jeu
est ce qu'un référendum à une valeur
après dire que c'est des gens votent oui
on est le président et forcés de les
parler de lui même avait expliqué s'il
devait expliquer la dernière fois que
c'était c'était pas pareil que c'était
un référendum qui n'était pas nationale
donc donc oui donc quel est son nom mais
voilà donc nous donc ma question aux
trois constitutionnaliste est ce qu est
ce qu un référendum c'est le peuple vote
oui et une question disent que le
président est obligé de prendre acte à
venir au québec d'aller voter oui donc
ça va il peut son souffle oui
théoriquement oui néanmoins c'est vrai
que je pense que tu as en tête le
référendum de 2005 est en réalité on
peut on peut distinguer les étapes dans
ce référendum parce que le référendum de
2005 a bloqué le pourquoi quand on dit
qu'on l'appliqué alors que l'été on a
appris qu'il réfère à nominingue
enveloppe encore que c'est une nouvelle
aile c'est pas du tout la même chose
pour ce qui était beau le référendum de
vue chaque sac comme moi ce que dit ce
qu'on dit souvent pendant ce que disent
les compartiments du pontet nyon c'est
là qu'est le tapis
sans réaliser la plupart du temps autour
de questions législatives et non en fait
ça a valeur pleinement législatives est
ce qui m
benoît valeur de l'eau est elle un
curieux c'est que en cas de saisine du
conseil constitutionnel celui-ci se
déclarent même incompétent pour exercer
un contrôle de constitution était certes
même le peuple si dit quelque chose dans
une loi même si ces contrats la
constitution ça s'impose elle est une
question pour faire rire jean charles
pratique loose noir tepco alors il ya 2
dont il expliqué il ya deux deux
articles qui permettent le référendum
dans la constitution de la vème
république l'article ou rosé l'article
89 de gaulle utilisé mais quel est ce
qu'ils disent alors seulement je
commence par 89 alors normalement au
regard de la constitution le référendum
ne peut passer que par la voix de
l'article 89 de la constitution article
89 de la constitution qui prévoit que
l'initiative appartient au président a
public sur proposition du gouvernement
ou un parlementaire il faut dans un
second temps un vote des deux assemblées
et dans un troisième temps si ce vote
est favorable
un référendum est engagée par voie
d'exception le projet de révision de la
constitution peut être à là à
l'initiative du président peut être
déposée enfin être traité par le
parlement réuni en congrès est donc dans
ce cas là on n'échappe à la voix
profonde échappe à la ba du référendum
donc ça c'est la voix qui est classe 89
ceci dit le général de gaulle il est la
risée longue parole alors il faut
d'abord aussi précisé qu'on ne parle que
du référendum c'est bien le mercure
s'ils se produisent bientôt on passera
la mission ça fait mal précisons d'être
avec photo de gauche extraits précisons
que nous ne parle que des référendum
constituant c'est à dire qu'ils ont pour
objet de réviser la constitution
sinon les référendum pour une loi pour
l'abolition de la peine de mort ou etc
ça serait des référendum de l'article 11
dans tous les cas l'article 80 heures
c'est uniquement pour réviser la
constitution et normalement ça n'est que
l'article 89 mais le général de gaulle a
utilisé à deux reprises
l'article 11 parce que le référendum
portait sur toute question dite
institutionnelle est relative à
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics et
le général de gaulle a interprété cette
organisation des pouvoirs publics comme
pouvant dire qu'on pouvait donc utiliser
ce référendum directement du faubourg
bin voila c'est vrai que la constitution
est ambiante but et c'est très utile
parce que du coup vous pourriez opter
complètement nous de partout voilà
emmanuel macron avec la réforme
constitutionnelle qu'il avait ambitionné
l'année dernière avait fait savoir qu'il
ne s'interdisait pas d'utiliser cet
article 11 parce que on sait gérard
larcher a été complètement hostile à son
projet de réforme constitutionnelle
et si ya un référendum le jour des
grands débats la suite open 26 mai sa
vie on veut pas passer par le 80 faux
pas et on n'a plus le temps non mais ça
n'est pas un référendum constituant
puisque rien ne sera intégrée dans la
constitution la balle friands de députés
de sénateurs par exemple malheureusement
c'est qu'on ne connaît pas le périmètre
de ce référendum c'est qu'on ne sait pas
ce qu'il va y avoir à l'intérieur donc
normalement de modification de la
constitution pour organiser un
référendum rapidement volera pas mais si
ce référendum ne porte que sur des
questions qui font l'objet de la loi et
bien il suffira d'utiliser l'article 11
et ça peut se faire en simple quinze
jours de campagne
c'est l'essai alors sachant qu'il ya
également
fait indemne initiative parlementaire
soutenue par certains mais évidemment le
gilet jaune fait plutôt un référendum
d'initiative populaire prévu par l
afin de mener cette citoyenne qui est
encore autre chose justement
jusqu'à présent il ya une sorte de là
chaque fois qu'il y ait un référendum
s'il y avait une sorte de drap comme
celle qui suit l'idée d'avoir plusieurs
questions dans un référendum ce qui
semblerait être le cas si le référendum
ait lieu
c'est une façon de dédramatiser ce que
vous pouvez répondre oui à l'une ou à
l'autre donc je veux dire du coup le pré
il fallait la personne qui pose la
question des plus opposés politiquement
c'est génial parce qu'effectivement
quelles que soient les réponses qu'elle
aura tellement ça sert tellement
compliqué que personne pour en tirer le
moindre enseignement niaba la rue là
pour ça oui on peut on peut dire qu'ils
sont vraiment contre macro mais pour ça
ils sont à fond pour et plus ils sont un
peu mitigé villa c'est plutôt pour
edouard philippe
et là c'est peut-être un petit coup de
pied pour marine le pen et mais je pense
que mélenchon devrait être ça ne sais
pas c'est un g20 griveaux qui a qualifié
sa de gloubiboulga politique c'est joli
à kazim kazim et rhume et honnêtement la
force et nous manque beaucoup
mais s'ils n'étaient pas là gilet jaune
le complotisme ça bizarre le complot
teese est un petit peu sur des gens qui
vous écoute
[Rires]
mais il ya 10% je crois un des français
croient au complot 10 mhz et 79 %
d'entre eux croient au moins en une
théorie complotiste et l'at-elle et
laquelle laquelle vous voyez vous
apprends moi je crois qu'on nous écoute
il faut quand même faire une différence
parce que j'ai l'impression que tout le
monde mélange un peu les théories du
complot c'est quelque chose de
monstrueux du d'une bêtise vous êtes
lire par exemple se bat les attentats
c'est pas des attentats c'est le
gouvernement qui les attentats
terroristes ont eu lieu ces deux
gouvernements parce qu'il y avait le
mouvement des jaunes donc pour dériver
l'attention de la bonne opinion
ils ont créé un attentat voilà par
exemple si on est tout à fait d'accord
c'est la théorie du complot c'est
stupide
on est tous d'accord en revanche des
gens qui peuvent penser que lady di
aurait été assassiné c'est pas une
théorie du complot c'est une idée qui
peut-être un peu farfelue mais on peut
aussi avoir de temps en temps une idée
sur une explication l'événement qui
n'est pas forcément complotistes voilà
c'est ce qu'on dit par complotisme parce
qu'officiellement tout cela rentre dans
une théorie du complot c'est à dire que
c'est très mal dit d'ailleurs de dire
théorie du complot mais ce qu'on appelle
théorie du complot est une forme de
scepticisme c'est à dire de dire que les
explications officielles cache peut-être
des objets des explications officieuse
est le propre d'une théorie du complot
c'est justement de ne pas pouvoir être
contredite puisque toute contradiction
abreuve la théorie du complot il n'y a
pas eu les intendants du ça commence
plutôt la révolution la révolution
française n'est pas une révolution
française c'est finalement le club des
jacobins et les différents clubs de
penser qu'ils ont fomenté ça peut aller
avec la déclaration d'indépendance les
dollars américains
donc les illuminati les francs-maçons il
y en a eu
les drames qu'on a vécu c'est quand les
pointus on nous cache tout on nous dit
rien comme dit c'est moi je pense qu'il
ya un complot parce que la 27 % des
français pensent que les illuminati nous
manipulent je suis intimement persuadé
qu'il n'ya pas 27% des français qui
connaissent les siciliens personnel ça
qu'ils soient liés les vols de nombreux
sondages et nominative peut-être que oui
peut-être une nation des champs-elysées
besson pour mais qui sont là qui sont
vraiment les jumeaux mais alors ça dit
ça dit quoi aux fossettes cette
sensation qu'on nous dit pas tout quoi
enfin comment classer phase iib beaucoup
de bêtises sur le 11 septembre
oui et des choses qu'on a cité mais
c'est vrai que ça dit aussi beaucoup sur
le scepticisme des françaises y habitent
des discours officiels et notamment des
médias médias qui qui sont quand même
très largement pointés du doigt et on
peut le dire assez a raison moi je
déconseille mama les étudiants s'ils
veulent se cultiver d'aller dans les
médias en tout cas traditionnel afin
d'aller prendre l'information sur sur
sur des chaînes d'information continue
d'avoir des des médias un peu plus
spécialisés qui existe mais c'est vrai
que les gens ne pas fait pas forcément
ce réflexe là et puis il y à une
simplification des discours il ya des
éléments qu'on ne donne pas il ya un
discours qui est assez dominant kippa
plurielle et donc en fait les français
ne se reconnaissent pas dans ce qu'ils
entendent dans ce qu'ils le voient à la
télé en ce qu'ils entendent à la radio
et donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut
notamment créer des émissions comme
celle-là et et même plus largement
effectivement il faut il faut réfléchir
effectivement sur
sur sur la place des médias sur le
renouvellement aussi estimé certains qui
tombe pas c'est ben oui extrêmement
inquiète derrière ça aussi que ce qu'il
ya et sert qu'il ya le lan vie de ne pas
réfléchir ne pas essayer de on est quand
même dans une démocratie pluraliste où
en effet il y en a pour tout le monde
alors on peut se caler sur ce ce truc
infâme qui s'appelle russia today
les chaînes la chaîne du kremlin qui est
paraît-il la plus regardée nécessaire
conclut par exemple de penser qu'il ya
peut-être derrière les mouvements co qui
ont lieu actuellement la main de
puissances extérieures qui voudraient
déstabiliser la 132 la france non il ya
sept la noce sur exemple plusieurs la
main mais qui sont peut-être pas très
efficace mais il ya peut-être des petits
appels du pied etc
mais mais mais je veux être parmi les
casseurs des gens qui viennent
d'ailleurs ça arrive sûrement mais c'est
parce qu'ils expliquent l'essentiel des
choses mais il ya derrière ce ce type là
avec sa casquette quel grand penseur
l'un des grands penseurs la kiffer sel
c'est live sur facebook devrait déjà
comme par hasard c'est lui qui les
disent élevés notamment son ami
voilà qui donne l'impression que dès
qu'on a un gilet jaune on peut dire les
pires conneries en bénéficiant d'une
immunité absolue surtout pas critiquer
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui souffre et
ses séquences à cape d'harry potter
c'est le cas d'un d'invisibilité l'asie
mineure et immunités j'étais si vous
voulez relire une météo est exactement
ça et est donc mais voilà il faut il
faut réfléchir il faut aller voir
écouter ou lire d'autres choses et il ya
ce qu'il faut pour se forger une opinion
qui qui ne qu'ils puissent se dispenser
de cette facilité de cette paresse qui
consiste à dire ouh là là oui on nous
dit ça mais j'y crois pas et alors soit
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on fait où est
la vérité
il faut aller la chercher et on peut la
chercher aussi dans le débat
dans la délibération mois de deux points
en danger
de cette théorie du complot est une
raison la raison peut-être d'abord c'est
qu'à mon avis c'est le sentiment
d'injustice dans l'histoire qui a
toujours alimenté cette théorie du
complot c'est à dire que certains ont
l'impression qu'ils n'ont pas accès à
des choses que d'autres où ça je pense
que c'est l'une des premières l'une des
premières raisons et le danger c'est au
moins deux dangers qui se sont réalisés
dans l'histoire c'est le complot anti
sémite qui nous a quand même mené
jusqu'à une guerre mondiale et puis
aussi peut-être le maccarthysme la
question de l'anticommunisme qui avait
créé aussi ce qui m'a tensions avec la
guerre froide et ça prouve qu à chaque
fois qu on se fie à ce type de théorie
quand politiquement ça peut avoir un
impact on peut courir un réel danger et
on à donald trump aux états unis des
censeurs remis à parler d'effet ligne
aux usages de sio voilà protocoles des
sages de sion il faut mais voilà il
reposer heureusement servir
politiquement et là c'est vraiment
dangereux
cela dit on en est pas encore faut se
rassurer parce qu'on nommait pas qu'il
avait l'air très inquiet non mais quand
même pas au niveau des américains est
comme un américain sur quatre qui
pensent qu elvis presley vivons quand
même d'accord donc de lait chocolaté
sort du pis de la vache
cela dit les théories du complot siro si
on regarde de rapidement elles sont
encore plus forte les gens qui n'ont pas
d'élus et c'est pas toujours parce que
dans l'histoire ils se sont souvent des
bruits gênants minuit intellectuels
locaux nommés hier il ya aussi ceux qui
conçoivent
oui mais ce qu'il est un grand joueur
carlos ghosn il est victime d'un complot
visait initialement complot de missane
des japonais et c'est bon là je pense
que il fait tout quand même pour
confirmer que papa trop non cela me
disais tout à l'heure
rien ne l'arrête enfin à parler japonais
mais sinon
il est saisissant dernière trucks et il
était pas au courant mais il est prêt à
rembourser et c'est oui alors
florissante avait d'ailleurs on n'a pas
le temps de le passer mais un sujet qui
expliquait très bien le partenariat de
mécénat entre entre renault et le
château de versailles
après rennes c'est ce que dit son avocat
on peut supposer que les délais pdg de
grandes bottes ça ne s'occupe pas
directement de savoir qu'il paye les
factures abin sûr quand même si on peut
être le plus de cinquante années ont
décidé de se marier en costumes d'époque
au château de versailles je pensais
quand même ça peut venir à l'idée
d'amener tient mais mais comment est-ce
qu'il faut quoi est-ce qu'on doive
château de versailles est ce que ce pays
est ce que est ce que c'est chez à ce
que s'est passé c'est qu'ils vont être
même pas se poser la question enfin vous
annoncer il est vraiment à des années
lumière de nous c'était très beau oui
c'est là la grille et jaune
oui enfin bon et et daurelle message dit
je dis ça je dis rien voilà les bombes a
dit ça on va dire il veut tout cas si un
film est pas en termes d image jean
baptiste du club stéphane rousseau et
jean charles lajoie dit je rappelle
rafale de marque
falvo si vous voulez passer un bon
moment un bon match un vrai roman n'est
qu'après au mont noir
merci à tous bar très vite pour un
nouveau numéro de paf
[Musique]